when the first iPhone came out in 2007
everyone thought it was way too big it
had a 3.5 inch screen that was huge now
not even a decade later we're all
carrying around these giant phones with
giant screens well not everyone it turns
out there's a surprising number of
people who don't want a huge phone and
this the iPhone se is for those people
this phone is just like the iPhone 5s
which came out two years ago on the
outside other than a couple of tiny
changes it's identical on the inside
it's the iPhone 6s which means it's
super fast has a great camera all that
good stuff
battery life is fantastic actually even
better than the success which is awesome
the selfie camera is a lot worse than
the success but that's the only real
downside here so what's it like carrying
around a smaller phone there are some
upsides you won't drop your phone as
often you won't do that crazy thing
where you keep your phone from sliding
out of your hand by balancing it on your
pinkie you don't have to deal with
Apple's stupid reach ability feature
anymore you can use it with only one
hand typing or scrolling without having
to put down your cappuccino it makes
your phone feel faster and more
efficient like you're not constantly
clumsily trying to make it work no
matter who you are and especially a few
of small hands that part's amazing there
are some bad parts though for a visually
oriented person it sucks
movies and pictures just don't look as
impressive on the tiny screen forget
dropping this thing into a VR headset
it's just a blurry mess and you'll spend
a lot more time scrolling when all you
can see is a couple of tweets or like
3/4 of an Instagram photo our phones are
so immersive nowadays that going back to
something this small feels almost quaint
but look for 399 bucks or $4.99 with a
much more usable 64 gigs of storage the
iPhone se is an awesome phone yeah it's
small
who cares small things can be great